hey i have something unbelievable for
you
last week in the morning friday morning
fox news was gleefully gleefully
predicting a disastrous jobs report they
were doing coverage all morning it's
going to be terrible it's going to be
terrible they were rooting for our
failure
which they say we do which of course we
don't they were they were rooting
against america
and then the jobs report came in
and it was fantastic it was it was an
incredible jobs report that we actually
had us added over 450 000 jobs in
january 2022 strong demand at
restaurants retailers mail and parcel
delivery leisure and hospitality added
more than 150 000 jobs retail added 61
000 i mean just incredible numbers
and fox had to then just go silent
you have to see this here is the morning
on fox
before the jobs report and the next hour
the january job report will be released
and it could be the worst in years the
white house has been bracing for a bad
number it could be a loss of 300 000
jobs how's the white house going to put
a happy face on that wall the real
question is how are you going to put a
sad face on the incredible numbers we
got he thinks that we might see a loss
of hundreds of thousands of jobs it
could be a morning of pain because just
about 28 minutes from right now the
january jobs report is going to be
released by the bureau of labor and
whatnot projection is for an already low
150 000 jobs added but adp the company
that processes payrolls says to expect
301 000 jobs lost that would be a half a
million jobs swing the wrong way the
biden administration bracing for yet
another economic bus we're going to
bring you the january jobs report soon
after well didn't work out that way the
january jobs report just released the us
adding
467 000 jobs left so they they did
ultimately report on the numbers
and many of these people going
completely
and totally silent
uh some funny uh one funny graphic that
they had was this like completely
uh
negative catastrophic more job losses
and huge red font february 4th 2022
and of course it didn't happen now you
can always ask questions like well what
is the quality of these jobs uh what are
the wages of the these we always ask
these questions this is not a partisan
thing for me
when you know i was the first to tell
you during the trump administration the
economy was mostly doing very well
whether it had anything to do with trump
was a real question whether these jobs
numbers have anything to do with biden
is a completely fair question but the
rooting against america which i always
thought they said we did
even though they do it is just another
instance of projection and this is
completely beyond parody this is
later on
steve ducey asking stuart varney how did
everybody get it so wrong all right the
january jobs report is in white house
should be happy about that steve over to
you all right thank you very much carly
let's bring in stuart barney host of
varney and company and american built on
fox business stuart you know
this morning we were projecting what uh
one estimate was 150 000 or it could
have been 300 000 in the hole right it's
close to half a million how did
everybody get this so wrong well you're
right everybody did get this chronically
wrong i'm not sure i can really explain
why we've got this explosion of 467 000
jobs because it does run counter to what
we were expecting we thought that covid
or omicron in particular would be
keeping millions of people at home they
would not be at work and that would be
jobs lost now what's funny is they
didn't originally think that like they
downplayed omicron they downplayed
reports from fouchy and others we could
have fifteen twenty percent of the
population outside they but now they're
saying no i mean based on all that stuff
which we rejected for weeks we were
expecting it to be bad well it didn't
work out that way i'm sure that millions
of people are at home suffering from
omicron and this these figures were
taken in january but the overall number
was still way up there i can explain one
thing here the unemployment rate went up
from 3.9 to 4 it went up right now that
so
that actually isn't necessarily a bad
thing now i i we've talked about and
again you
fact check me go back and look at how i
cover jobs okay it it's not a partisan
thing for me
sometimes the unemployment rate goes up
because more people are starting to look
for jobs when you are actively looking
for a job you are considered unemployed
if you stop looking you are no longer
considered unemployed this was the case
under reagan under cl this is just this
is what it is and i don't play these
games where i ignore how these things
are measured depending on who's in the
white house i don't care about political
party
but sometimes
when the economy is getting better
more people say i now want to re-enter
the workforce and they become considered
actively unemployed so it doesn't tell
us much that the unemployment rate went
from i think 3.9 to 4.0
um it and and uh we're going to continue
covering this in the same
empirical way that we've been from the
beginning but how sad they were over at
fox
that the jobs report was good
let me know your thoughts you can find
me on twitter at d pacman and we'll be
right back
as someone who watches youtube you know
how annoying it is to watch ads at the
beginning of videos that are completely
irrelevant to the content you're
watching that's why you always click the
skip ad button our sponsor thought
leaders has just launched a new
targeting tool that allows advertisers
to choose the precise videos where their
ads will appear using the advanced
search in the thought leaders platform
which is powered by ai you can actually
find youtube videos relevant to your
brand's messaging and with thought
leaders precision targeting you can
really make every view count optimize
your ad spend improve your conversions
when brands put their ads on relevant
videos they catch their audience when
they are most receptive and create a
more fulfilling enjoyable youtube
experience for everyone involved plans
start at just 60 a month but you can try
it now for just 30 for the first month
when you click the link below and use
the code pacman at checkout